I want to show you a clip now of Tucker
Carlson doing his new show which is on X
Twitter whatever you want to call it
talking to Dave Portnoy Now Dave Portnoy
we've showed some clips of him over the
years from bar stool Sports he is
another I would say digital Pioneer
right he wanted to do a sports thing he
saw how ESPN corporate ABC Disney owned
ESPN was going completely woke he
started bar stool Sports it absolutely
blew up then he then of course the
machine tried to cancel him all sorts of
stuff but he has turned it into an
absolute Sports and culture uh cultural
Powerhouse and he and Tucker sat down
over the weekend now let me ask you this
before the fox unwinded you mean I got
fired yes did you think you like were
you uh Ardent like go fox go guy or do
you my view on Fox hasn't really changed
they let me say whatever I want whatever
I wanted really for 14 years and I I'll
never stop being grateful for that
and then obviously I said too much and
I'm not exactly sure what I said that
was bad no one ever told me but one day
they're like oh can't have this anymore
and they fired me
and I even told them as they were firing
me like your business I made a Ben still
up never worked for anyone else again
and I never will but
um I can't be mad about it I mean they
were they were great to me I thought the
murdochs were always nice to me and uh
and one day for whatever reason they'd
had enough so I wasn't my feelings
weren't hurt I was not expecting it so
were you like one for me when I was with
pen I knew there were things it's like
oh I can't go there they've made that
clear did you feel like that foxy could
say whatever you want well there was
always internal I mean did the murdochs
were always nice they never got in my
way at all they were always super nice
to me but there were you know small ma
it's a company run by fearful women yeah
you know what I mean and they were
always like neck you know second-tier
people who are hassling my producers but
no one ever called me I got along with
everybody but I mean I think they knew
like the censorship is it's not like I'm
not don't welcome that you know so um
but they never actually got in the way
of anything our view on the war in
Ukraine was really really hated I could
feel it and my view was not pro-russia
never has been pro-russia just like this
is not our fight it's not good for us we
should just put an end to the war
because people die in war I've seen it
it's bad
and just saying that was considered like
crazy Pro Kremlin propaganda and they
were very mad about that but to their
credit they never said anything to me
about it directly I could just smell it
and uh
so I I really just don't have any
complaints and I will say and I know
that you've experienced this you know
it's true being humiliated in public
being fired I have been a couple of
times is totally good for you in the end
because it keeps you from thinking
you're Jesus or like getting like super
crazy hubris guy you know company run by
fearful women I don't mean to make this
about fox and I do go on Fox obviously
I'm sure I'll be on Fox later this week
they always let me say whatever I want
so I don't want to focus on Fox so
specifically here but this idea of these
sort of accompany run by like middle
management I don't think it means it
matters if they're men or women
specifically like this managerial class
not the people who build anything right
so in that case the murdochs they built
the company right they built the media
Empire and not the people who tell the
people what they want to communicate
right like so Tucker is out there as the
as the star of the network so he's
producing something they're producing
the freaking pipes and the
infrastructure that allows people to
hear it but that there's this managerial
class in the middle and we see this
almost with everything in society
there's a bunch of people who create
almost nothing other than problems right
and they seem to be the ones that as
Tucker was saying didn't want Tucker to
say whatever it is that he wanted to say
now I also I also thought it was
interesting that what Tucker said there
was that he will never have another boss
like this I'm telling you guys like it's
been obvious to me for a long time I
think if you've watched me uh for if
you've watched me certainly for these 11
years the beginning of that 2013 thing
to now but even if you've only watched
me for the last year like this battle
between mainstream media and whatever is
happening online not to say me or Tucker
or Rogan or Bill Maher is right about
everything
and we may all have our weak spots and
blind spots and all of those things
actually I have no doubt that we do and
I'm pretty sure they would all admit
that as well but the battle between
something that has been hyper controlled
that that feeds us lie after lie after
lie and gets people to swallow the lies
and then say thank you Mark and I thank
you sir may I have another versus the
bunch of people trying to figure out
something something sensible